take life by its throat do something
stopping scared the reason people don't
put themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
the answer is add more people with
positivity and optimism and cut people
with pessimism and cynicism who you
surround yourself matters what's that
belief nation it's Evan my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see explode out onto the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and join today's lessons from a
man who went from being born in the
Soviet Union and hustling selling
flowers when he was a kid
to wanted to become the greatest
entrepreneur of his generation he's Gary
Vaynerchuk and he was my take on his top
ten most success volume for joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one kick life by the throat just
enough enough enough like living by
somebody else's rules is a humongous
mistake I've just literally sat down
with five people under the age of 27 and
it's so refreshing it is so refreshing
if you have not jumped on the bandwagon
of doing exactly what the you want to do
which is skiing for the next three years
or working at a job that's not what your
parents want or what society wants this
video is just called enough enough make
this little in one two minute video
depends on when I finish the piece of
content that gets you to stand up and
take life by its throat do something
stopping scared stop letting the way you
were raised the fear as an offence take
that away let me be the person I'll take
the blame I loved that some of my
employees are like my parents don't love
what you're saying
good parents because if you are playing
defense and if you are living a life
where your kids lives are the way you're
being fulfilled you're a loser
parents and so enough enough parents
imposing their way you want your kids to
be happy on your terms enough the kid
that's sitting right now in a desk and
saw this in a feed and you hate your job
enough stand up get the out of here and
do you live your life you've got one
life do something about it rule number
two is add value
and follow on instagram and facebook
page for PR do you really think that was
a good idea I know bro I honestly think
that that was one of like the worst
moves I've ever seen because I'm not
trying to razz you either I am talking
I'm trying to give you love I love the
passion to win the problem is you tried
to close on the first move you brought
them no value and you asked them to
bring you value like you gave like I
will stand up here and give a load of
value and never mention one time for any
of them to follow me and a lot more of
them will follow me then they're gonna
follow that bull move that you just did
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always gonna lose you can't go tonight
when you go out in Vegas and you see a
pretty girl at the bar you can't go up
to her and the opening move is like
here's my key let's go but but that's
what you just did let them hold it but
that's what you just did to this
audience with business because I mean
because doing the right thing is the
right thing
karma is practical you know I heard
somebody rant earlier right that's like
hey when I win I don't think it's coming
out of you the guy that closed I
couldn't know who was on stage but I
believed in that right because I love
the idea of 85 people here going and
listening to me winning I didn't make
anything for it but it then becomes
brand if she goes out and listens and
then two years later she's having dinner
with a friend and she's talking about
what happened to her life that friend
might be the CEO of GE you know I'm
playing with the biggest brands in the
world I'm not trying to monetize my
audience I'm trying to like just bring
the most value in the world and let that
lift all my other opportunities so I
think I think giving away your best
secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99% of these people
are not going to do anything about it
the somewhere about five or six years
ago I realized this fact holy people
aren't going to do anything with this so
like there's still gonna be plenty for
me and I'm gonna be the most lovable guy
ever I love this rule number three be
ambitious my success is that I prefer
change I'm comfortable and change and I
realize change is the only thing that
allows you to win in the long term the
98% of the human race and maybe hired
doesn't like it we are having a macro
change
we're having a societal change you know
like I'll be honest with you I'm like
ambitious and realistic one of the
biggest reasons I kind of went even
harder core at my personal brand like 15
months ago like back to what's worked
for us which is like hey here's my
example at least it's something to hold
I was like yeah I'm gonna make myself
the most famous person in America on
this fishery and then they'll be
undeniable and by the way it's working
I'm really good at underpriced attention
and culture I really am
you know it's so funny you start
realizing your life so I was good at
baseball cards
I decided Frank Thomas and Kenny Lofton
we're gonna be better than most people
thought so I just bought a lot of rookie
cards for underpriced costs and I was
right but what I'm really great at is I
understand consumer behavior and
attention just fast enough and earlier
than most people and I've got an uncanny
ability of that let me build a machine
around that that's over the last nine
years I've built a company called Manor
media we're 200 million dollar company
and revenue with no funding that does
agency work and we own a female
publishing company like a refinery29 and
my ambition is to build out the
communication Deathstar to deploy it
against my personal brand the
nonprofit's I care about but ultimately
my goal
by the New York Jets and the way I think
I'm gonna do that is I'm gonna buy
iconic brands and things that mattered
in the world that are gonna get Dover
next decade and then I'm going to
rebrand them and run them through my
machine and so I'm you know I'm building
this huge agency media company that is
really just a front and a proxy for my
long-term ambitions
it just it pleads underpriced attention
and culture more efficiently than I
think any other machine out there right
now and that's why cool things are
happening for me
rule number four seize the opportunity
you weren't born into a rich family
you're the wrong skin tone you're this
you're that I get it but just like God
we got to get back
you got that you won the lotto you want
it you've got to get back do something
with it
especially now your grandparents didn't
have this the internet is crazy it just
is it just is and so why do you think
everybody's getting out in now because
three old white guys don't control the
media anymore the do you think is
happening here this is the greatest fear
ever for anybody the market the platform
is the Internet this is unbelievable
unprecedented times we will look back at
this 200 years from now like these had a
good opportunity this is buying realist
do somebody bought the land that we're
on right now for a dollar at one point
that's what's happening with us on the
Internet the attention of the end
consumer is cheap right now you could
grab it around whatever you want to be
about and it doesn't cost you anything
other than your time and so many of you
are complaining but then are too fancy
to put in the 15 hours a day to get it I
got no respect for that I got no respect
for anybody who complains and isn't
putting in the work because it's an
excuse to not do will number 5 get
experience you've got a try stop
the biggest reason you don't know what
you want to do is you haven't tasted
enough things and the biggest reason
you're not tasting enough things is
you're worried about finding it too fast
start with the finish line all right too
many people are just worried about
tomorrow go backwards from what you want
to achieve financially and in your
legacy and then make all your behavior
every day map to your finish line
the way that it can that a 20 year old
can make the world better twenty or
thirty years down the line is by making
themselves better first I think I think
people don't realize that the way to be
selfless is to be selfish it's very hard
to change the world if you're not good
to me when I look around this many
people being in their 20s like
everybody's judging themselves way too
early what I would do is gather as many
experiences as possible you know you're
not lost in life they're just early in
the process rule number six get
attention there is ridiculous confusion
in the system I am winning and will win
at all-time levels get ready you will
tell your grandkids that you once saw me
live like I mean that and by the way
it's not because by the way I don't by
the way real quick cuz I don't want
claps for that I need you to understand
how I think about that it's not because
I think I'm fancy or great I think it's
because I'm very common simple about one
simple tiny thing underpriced the
tension it's so grossly underpriced I'm
asking you let me tell you this story
about MTV when MTV came out in the early
to mid 80s how many people remember when
MTV was launched when empty when MTV was
launched the biggest bands in the world
the biggest bands in the world got
together for a dinner that one of their
managers told me about and decided that
they would not make music videos for MTV
because that was giving away music for
free that why would we spend money to
make a video put it on MTV but when
that's giving people the music for free
and they will not go out and buy the
record at the same token up in
coming artists Madonna Duran Duran and
on and on understood that it was where
all the attention of the youth was and
it was a gateway drug to the sale they
understood that MTV was a jab not the
right hook Facebook and Instagram at
this second is the most underpriced
scaled jab in the history of marketing
except for one other moment from 2001 to
2005 Google AdWords was a ridiculously
under priced jab how many people here
took advantage of Google 2001 to 2005
raise your hands so for you you really
know that's how I did it
Wine Library had no money but when
you're buying people who want to buy
wine for five and ten cents a click it
works out real fast when it's that
underpriced one company one company
during that time acted the way I'm
aspiring to act right now as Gary
Vaynerchuk on social media one company
from 2001 to 2005 spent enough to
justify how underpriced it was that
company was a small book company called
Amazon Amazon as you all know now is the
company of our world it will win
everything it hasn't even begun
literally the only thing that will stop
Amazon is antitrust government
involvement otherwise it will destroy
everything
it got its fuel from Google 2001 to 2005
that occurrence is happening right now
on Facebook and Instagram and we're not
squeezing the juice out of that fruit
anywhere close at least we have picked
up the fruit rule number seven ignore
the opinions of others on a bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much which then
dictates their behavior which then gets
into all of this Wise's if you like
don't hold on to it and with the thought
of in case it fails because you just
need to realize it's your Scarlet Letter
literally the reason people are scared
always is the outside force having a
failing business and everyone's like Oh
see you could never do or whatever the
cliche is right yeah it just doesn't
matter you know why so that's one piece
I mean even if it didn't succeed
what there's such better people like
what I'm such a better person than other
people because I can build a business
that's [ __ ] rule number eight change
your environment I'm getting more and
more intrigued by mindset because I used
to think of it as fluffy like self-help
and now I think it more as strategy
what's your strategy in life somebody
asked me on Instagram after I posted a
scary if the mindset has been skewed how
can you bring it back and I answered
with by surrounding yourself with people
who have the mindset you aspire to my
friends please understand that mindset
is controllable in the same way that all
our opinions are controllable the key is
to add more people with optimism and cut
people with negativity it's very very
simple now it's very hard to cut people
with pessimism cynicism and negativity
when they are the people that are the
closest to you parents siblings spouse
but the bottom line is if you're asking
the question I'm gonna give you the
answer the answer is add more people
with positivity and optimism and cut
people with pessimism and cynicism who
you surround yourself matters what
content you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offense and optimism and now I
know no different please do the same for
you make that move mold and I mean mold
your mindset by
you consume and with whom you consume it
I would argue that well more than 50% of
the people in this audience are here
today because they worry about the way
they would be judged by one and or two
family members in their you know seven
eight people circle if you're not
feeling it find new friends I'm being
dead serious about this this one is real
big for me who you hang out with is a
huge ionic and these are all trying true
things right we've heard the your than
whatever of the five friends you spent
like that's real add one new winner
friend like you know what I mean I had
one new winner friend and cut one loser
friend like yeah I know he's been your
boy since fourth grade but he sits at
home and smokes weed and plays 2k all
day like you can only love them so much
rule number nine go all-in I know that
if I can suffocate all of you today to
take 25% of your take-home income this
year and pour it back into two people
who do video and written word and put it
into Facebook and Instagram ads
literally all of you will email me 24
months actually get if you can start
right away literally 25% of you are
going to come to me this time next year
right here and be like holy [ __ ] been
listening to your stuff for seven years
your keynote was different in Miami last
year at this time I listened I said it I
don't need to go to Ibiza three times
this year yet I don't need to buy a
better BMW this year to make me feel
good with the neighbors yet I don't need
another pair of Supremes or Yeezys I
took the money and I put it into Karen
the film woman and Rick the ad guy and
now my business is 2x this will 100%
work even if you suck
on camera have zero charisma are only
eight days in the industry this will
work because it is such under priced
attention that the ROI will work that if
you're a to in skill the ads are a
twenty in the ten point scale and it
closes the Delta of you being average if
you literally literally and I've said
this for seven years if you literally
literally go interview the guy who owns
the gym in town the guy who owns the
pizza shop the woman that owns the
insurance brokerage if you literally
literally literally just interview your
local community that you become the
local newspaper in three minute video
form on your phone you don't even need
to hire the rock or babban rise your
phone if you literally take it selfie it
and interview the principal of the
school in your neighborhood you will
become the local celebrity who can then
transact on whatever you're trying to
sell that group if you bring value to
people if you interview the best high
school basketball player literally just
that your business will change or if you
literally just give the advice of how
you got here what you learned if you
shared your thoughts if you do not
understand that you were a media company
then you will not be as successful as
you are today in a decade and that's not
interesting when the alternative is
you're four to seven times bigger this
thick guys you have to understand what
happened to Blockbuster and Netflix what
happened with uber and taxi companies
what happened with hotels versus Airbnb
is happening with you as a human in your
business and so when you have the best
hand and you know it because you've been
paying attention and you know how to
play poker you go all-in
everybody here is playing Facebook
Instagram social media YouTube
podcasting like they have the best hand
and they're calling and you're not going
them into getting all the money you're
just folding and that's this audience so
can you imagine what I feel is going on
outside this Stadium
so this is a call to action for
everybody to do me one favor and I do
think I can get a lot of you to do it
which excites the [ __ ] out of me please
right now listen maybe you've laid out
money maybe you're in the middle of a
renovation maybe you're paying for your
kids college
Mazel Tov I know there's nuances on
everybody's life but if you are in a
position where literally your take-home
income this year is literally the stuff
you're gonna go and do things with
please from 25% to 90% if you can go
humble please take that money and hire
two people to make a lot more content
for you about you and your business and
please give the rest of the money to
Facebook and YouTube and Instagram and I
fundamentally promise you you will walk
here to this conference next year and
personally thank me emotionally because
your business will change and I know not
one of you has gone all-in and rule
number ten the last me for some very
special bonus Clips is love your
audience
come here
James you know else when you do a face
hey James it's Gary Vee I'm here with
your dad I'm really pissed that you're
not here but I respect that you're
hustling that's exactly what you should
be doing hope we get to be see it
now about three very special Gary
Vaynerchuk bonus clips for you around
being a good leader being self-aware and
having patience and I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that we're
getting to the commitment of the day you
guys just watch this video hopefully had
an impact on you somehow I want you to
commit to making a change somewhere in
your life or in your business leave it
down in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out don't just watch
another video without taking action
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon and enjoy the bonus clips
12 years ago today I asked somebody on
my team to run to Best Buy pick up a
little Canon camera set it up I picked
three bottles of wine and put them on a
table I filmed it first time I've ever
filmed anything with the purpose of
anybody seeing it hello everyone and
welcome to the first episode of Wine
Library TV I am Gary Vaynerchuk director
of operations here at Wine Library and
it started the process of where we are
here today twelve years later
when I hear people lacking patience or
wanting it so fast or not understanding
the marathon I've basically been
producing content for the internet for
the last 12 years and and I really wish
so many of you could understand how
quick that's gone and how much longer I
have to go but most of all realize how
much didn't happen in those first
several years
how much I needed to persevere and build
an audience how much engaging and
applying to people along the way and
building relationships and hugging and
kissing babies and grinding and
believing and and most of all what's so
interesting is I sit here right now
outside this Airport knowing that 65% of
you didn't know who I was 24 months ago
15 months ago that my current place of
attention is a current phenomenon it's a
15 16 month phenomenon that things kind
of took a little bit of a hockey stick
moment which means ten and a half years
10 1/2 years of grinding and putting out
stuff and wanting to share my thoughts
unwind on business entrepreneurship day
in and day out day in and day out Wow I
worked all the time building businesses
while this wasn't even my full-time
thing I have so much empathy that you
want it I'm so much everything I want
for you to get yours but Jesus this
doesn't happen overnight it just does it
everybody in here needs to take a step
back and get really self-aware really
quickly because self-awareness and
empathy are the two pillars that will
make you successful these are the two
things I do that nobody sees because of
my persona
because of other alpha characteristics I
have there's a disguised superpowers
that have gotten me here today but the
reality is a long time ago through
amazing parenting and the serendipity of
being an immigrant at the right time I
got real self-aware real fast and
started triple downing on what I was
versus pandering to everybody else and
so the security and confidence and all
the other things that were put into me
allowed me to be good at this game for
the last ten years and the reason I'm
stressing such an EQ kind of fluffy
thing to you it is the framework that
will allow you be successful it is
strategy either you have the right
strategy or even the wrong one
you can't you can't can't
what you can do is you can hustle and
then people will either ride up to it or
run away from it like you know I don't
judge my people first of all nobody that
works for you hustle as hard as you
period you want somebody to hustle as
hard as you that works for you give them
the same economics you're taking home
that's extreme number two with kids rich
kids aren't gonna care as much as you
about money because you didn't have any
and so you had a fight for it and then
that's just real so I think you said I
set the tone for my company some people
rise up some people find their work-life
balance some people bounce I'm not in
the game of thinking that's important if
I feel good about what I'm paying
somebody for for what I'm getting in
return I don't need to judge that they
need to work harder so I don't want to
get a deal for my people do you
understand
I want mighty people to be on my team
not me getting more value out of them
it's a huge mistake of business owners
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]